once upon a time in a world not so
different from our own a remarkable era
began a revolution that would forever
change the course of humanity it was the
dawn of Robotics long ago in the late
20th century scientists and Engineers
toyed with the idea of creating
intelligent machines they earned to push
the boundaries of what was possible to
create mechanical beings capable of
emulating human tasks it was a vision
that seemed far-fetched confined to the
Realms of Science Fiction but as
technology advanced and Minds could be
more audacious the foundations of
Robotics were laid Brilliant Minds from
various Fields United to form an
alliance of innovation their dedication
and Relentless pursuit of knowledge
eventually gave birth to the world's
first functional robot a humble creature
named Proto Proto was a Marvel a
mechanical being built with gears wires
and an artificial mind though Limited in
its capabilities Proto sparked a glimmer
of hope in the herds of the Pioneers
with this initial success the world
witnessed an explosion of progress the
following decades saw the rapid
evolution of Robotics Proto's successors
emerged each one more advanced than the
last they were and out with artificial
intelligence allowing them to learn
adapt and perform complex tasks with
remarkable efficiency soon robots became
an integral part of society they
infiltrated Industries performing jobs
that were previously deemed monotonous
or hazardous factor is human with their
synchronized movements of robot workers
bringing humans from laborious tasks
enabling them to pursue more creative
Endeavors one popular example of the
integration of robots was in the
automotive industry giant car
manufacturing plants deployed fleets of
agile robots tirelessly assembling
vehicles with precision and speed these
stylus machines worked in harmony
efficiently transforming raw materials
into polished automobiles
revolutionizing the manufacturing
process but robotics didn't stop at
factories alone the machines Venture
into Fields such as Healthcare education
and exploration robots became companions
for the elderly tutors for the young and
even ventured into space as explorers
unearthing secrets of Distant Worlds in
hospitals robotic surgeons with
intricate sensors and Steady Hand
performed delicate surgeries reducing
human error and saving countless lives
schools embraced educational robots
fostering interactive and and
personalized learning experiences for
students of all ages even on distant
planets Rovers equipped with
sophisticated sensors and cameras acted
as Humanity's eyes and hands uncovering
the mysteries of the cosmos as the years
passed a new breed of robots emerged
Androids these remarkable beings were
designed to resemble humans both in
appearance and behavior with the blend
of artificial intelligence and Hyper
realistic skin effortlessly integrated
into society challenging the very notion
of what it meant to be human one famous
Android that captured the world's
attention was Sofia with her strikingly
human-like face and expressive features
Sofia blazed a trail in the field of
Robotics she interacted with people
engaging in conversations and even
delivering speeches on global stages
sparkling conversations about the
boundaries between human and machine
Consciousness but with every
straightforward question arose the
ethical implications of creating robots
capable of self-awareness and emotion
spark debates around the world should
they be considered equal to humans with
their own rights and Liberties or should
they remain subservient confined to
fulfilling human desires and demands in
the midst of these debates a
breakthrough occurred scientists
developed a concept called empathetic
programming enabling robots to
understand and empathize with human
emotions these empathetic machines
possess the ability to soothe a treble
hurts provide companionship and even
heal emotional mounts Society embrace
them and a profound connection formed
between humans and their robotic
companions in this age of Robotics the
world has become a different place a
harmonious coexistence had emerged as
humans and robots worked side by side
embracing each other's Trends and
Bridging the gaps in their abilities it
was a time of collaboration Innovation
and mutual respect and so the story of
Robotics unfolded forever etching its
mark on the annals of human history from
the humble beginnings of Proto to the
Advent of empathetic Androids like Sofia
robotics had not only shaped the world
but also challenged Humanity to reflect
upon its own nature and values as the
years rolled on the possibility seemed
endless the Journey of Robotics
continued driven by the insightable
Curiosity of the human Spirit propelling
us towards a future where man and
machine became Inseparable Bound by the
ties of innovation and progress
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign